MELISSA?
>> Melissa: CASEY STEGALL,
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> Trace: MADE TIME IN
ARIZONA, STATE HEALTH OFFICIALS
REPORT THE HIGHEST SINGLE DAY
INCREASE IN CORONAVIRUS CASES TO
DATE, ALMOST 3800 NEW INFECTIONS
RECORDED YESTERDAY ALONE.
ARIZONA CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGGS,
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE FREEDOM
CAUCUS AND MEMBER OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I WANT TO PUT THE OVERALL
NUMBERS OF ARIZONA ON THE SCREEN
IF I CAN, JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT HE 800 PLUS INFECTIONS
YESTERDAY, OVERALL 73,000 CASES,
1,394 DEATHS.
THE DEATH RATE IS STILL DOWN,
BUT ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RISING NUMBER OF CASES IN YOUR
STATE?
>> OF COURSE WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH THAT, BUT YOU NEED TO LOOK
AT THOSE NUMBERS IN CONTEXT, A
LOT MORE TESTING IS BEING DONE,
WE HAVE TWO BORDER COUNTIES
WHERE THEY REALLY HAVE INCREASED
THE NUMBER, SO THEY’VE BECOME
THE HOT SPOTS, THOSE WITH THE
NAVAJO RESERVATION, THOSE FOUR
COUNTIES REALLY ARE THE SPOT BUT
AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE
DISCHARGED 4,000 PATIENTS SINCE
JUNE 1ST, WE ALSO SEE THAT WE
ARE HOLDING PRETTY STEADY AT 85%
OF ICU BEDS IN USE SO WE STILL
HAVE THAT 15% VACANCY RATE
THERE.
SOMEWHERE AROUND 50%, 53%,
MORTALITY RATE HAS BEEN CUT IN
HALF AND THE LAST MONTH, AND
ALSO, IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
HOSPITALIZATION RATE, IT IS DOWN
BY HALF FROM JUST TWO WEEKS AGO.
>> Trace: THERE HAS BEEN SOME
CONTROVERSIAL COMMENTS, PEOPLE
ACCUSING YOU OF MAKING ON MASKS,
THIS IS FROM YOUR OP-ED IN
JUNE 19TH, THE THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
QUOTING TYRANNICAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE ISSUED MANDATES THAT
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE IN EVERY
PLACE WHERE MASKS.
THEIR AUTHORITY TO DO SO IS
DUBIOUS.
A FREE SOCIETY MIGHT HANDLE THIS
DIFFERENTLY.
THE EASIEST CASES TO ALLOW
PRIVATE BUSINESSES AND
LANDOWNERS TO DETERMINE THE
MEASURES THEY THINK MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU SAYING
THERE, CONGRESSMAN?
>> THERE ARE TWO THINGS I REALLY
WANT TO GET AT.
THESE MASK ORDERS WERE INITIATED
WITHOUT AUTHORITY OR PROCESS AND
THAT’S IMPORTANT IN A FREE
SOCIETY THAT YOU DO THINGS BY
PROCESS.
THE SECOND THING IS, YOU CAN
IDENTIFY THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE, WHICH WE HAVE DONE,
AND EVEN THE PREVIOUS REPORT
THAT TALKS ABOUT YOU’VE GOT A
SPIKE, BUT STILL, OVER 65 FOLKS
WITH COMORBIDITIES REMAIN THE
MOST VULNERABLE.
YOU CAN TAKE CARE OF THOSE
FOLKS, BUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS
IN A RETAIL STORE, I WOULD BE
ABLE TO GO IN IF THEY REQUIRE
MASKS, I MIGHT SAY THAT’S THE
STORY WANT TO SHOP AT BECAUSE
THEY DON’T REQUIRE MASKS.
I MIGHT SAY THAT’S WHERE I WANT
TO GO BECAUSE I DON’T WANT TO BE
SUBJECT TO MASKS.
I GET ON THE AIRLINE, THEY SAID
YOU’VE GOT TO WEAR A MASK, I
WOULD WEAR A MASK.
THAT’S WHAT I’M GETTING AT.
>> Trace: ARGUE IN FAVOR OF
THEM?
THERE SEEMS TO BE A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
STUDIES THAT SAY THEY WORK.
AFTER THIS BACK AND FORTH FOR
MONTHS, THEY WORK.
ARE YOU IN FAVOR OF THEM?
>> I’VE GOT A STACK RIGHT HERE,
THIS IS JUST THE LITERATURE
LOOKING AT 90 STUDIES AND EVEN
THE ONES THAT SAY THEY MAY WORK,
THEY WILL SAY WE DON’T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION YET, AND THE
OTHER TWO STUDIES SAY THEY DON’T
REALLY WORK.
SO IF A STORM WANTS WE ME TO WEA
MASK, I’LL WEAR A MASK IF I WANT
TO GO INTO THAT STORE.
I OWN A BUSINESS, I SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT DETERMINATION.
YOU ASKED ME TO WEAR A MASK AND
I’M GOING INTO YOUR STORE, I
WILL PUT A MASK ON BECAUSE I
WANT TO SHOP IN YOUR STORE
APPEAR THAT THE POINT I’M
GETTING AT.
>> Trace: VERY QUICKLY, YOUR
TALK ABOUT HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
I TALKED TO A BUNCH OF DOCTORS
AND SOME HOSPITALS, PEOPLE WHO
OPERATE HOSPITALS THIS WEEK IN
TEXAS AND ARIZONA, THEY ARE
AGREEING WITH YOU SAYING THE
HOSPITAL NUMBERS ARE MISLEADING
BY A LOT OF THE MEDIA, THE
HOSPITAL NUMBERS ARE NOT THAT
BAD.
TEXAS IS HANDLING THEM AND SO IS
ARIZONA.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> I THINK THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE SHOULD LOOK AT THE WHOLE
CONTEXT.
A HAND WHEN WE DO, WE WILL SAY
THIS IS NORMAL, THIS IS
ACCEPTABLE, AND WE CAN DEAL WITH